hi it's ria today i've been challenged
to take a popular food and make it fancy
today's guest is jordan jones she's a
popular singer content creator and a
huge fan of makey fancy let's see what
i'm making fancy today hey really it's
jordan jones i'm so excited to be a
guest today on make it fancy i'm
obsessed with jolly ranchers so i'm
going to put you up to the test to make
jolly ranchers fancy the blue raspberry
jolly ranchers are my favorite i cannot
wait to go taste test soon and meet you
and make it fancy
jelly rancher i have had this before i
actually made a video i made aquarium
cookie and i use the jolly rancher it's
colorful and has a different flavor it's
very versatile ingredients for baking
very strong aroma i always confused
about blue raspberry flavor because
raspberry is not blue there is
watermelon
green apple blue raspberry
cherry does it taste like watermelon
oh yeah sweeter
intense version of watermelon i did
grape
tastes like a grape candy little grape
candy these are really cool so i think i
can make extra special today and as
always i'm excited to make it fancy
right here's what i got strawberries
pears there are a bunch of pears bear
with me
pair with me heavy cream butter eggs and
buttermilk from the pantry i got vanilla
extract baking soda corn syrup sugar
flour vegetable oil salt white chocolate
and vodka alright let's get started
make it fancy
we have cherry flavored jelly rancher
keep this in a pot and
melt completely
19
1949 how are you so good at history i
watch a lot of drunk history and it's
actually a very informative show once
you don't see any visible candy bits i'm
adding vodka and it's a lot of vodka one
cup
also jelly rancher is melted into vodka
take off from the heat and cool down it
takes about 15 minutes i'm adding one
pound of strawberry in a pot half cup of
sugar you cook this until softened mix
it up it will take about 10 minutes but
you don't want to burn on the bottom so
constantly mixing strawberry is cooked
nice and soft transfer this in the
blender puree this strawberry and sugar
mixture in a blender string so it's nice
and smooth add in jolly rancher vodka
syrup make it in total 2 cups next step
i'm going to use four gelatin sheets
cover with cold water to bloom make sure
it's submerged completely and while it's
blooming heat up vodka strawberry jolly
rancher puree i like the smell it's
fresh strawberry it's not smell too
artificial sometimes
especially cherry flavor smell like a
cough syrup gelatin is
soft and almost look like a jellyfish
add this into my puree whisk it make
sure it completely dissolved transfer to
this pan
let it cool for room temperature and put
in a refrigerator chill it about two to
four hours until it sets
so i have 25 jolly rancher put it in the
fridge processor makes very unpleasant
sounds so hold your ears
am i breaking this
shake it off and i just want to use this
kind of big pebble size one it's kind of
like all the timey looking for gold you
are scooping gold from the suns so i'm
gonna set this aside but we have plenty
more things to do using one stick of
room temperature butter just whip it
nicely
200 gram of sugar cream until fluffy
[Music]
i have three egg whites but i am adding
little by little
scraping side of the bowl so everything
is mixed nicely combine dry ingredients
200 grams of flour 1 and 1 4 teaspoon of
baking soda half tsp of salt lightly
mixed i have 5 ounces buttermilk quarter
cup of vegetable oil 1 teaspoon vanilla
extract so combine together and i'm
going to alternate dry ingredients and
wet ingredients
so everything is well combined add this
jolly rancher pebbles
it's kind of squeak like a dinosaur
maybe that's just my uh
i'm hallucinating
sometimes i don't remember if it was
dream or if it's really happened to me
adding in a cake pan bake this cake in
oven 350 degree about 20 to 25 minutes
do the toothpick test and when toothpick
comes out clean it's ready glue gelatin
two sheets covered with cold water one
and one fourth cup of heavy cream three
tablespoons of corn syrup two teaspoon
of vanilla bring to simmer
i don't think so
i saw a lot of people making first
lunchable episode stove top stuffing
brownie mix episode i made a swiss roll
but
i haven't seen people made miraculous
cake for eugene i think this one is also
difficult to come to a simmer jelly is
melted so i'm adding uh white chocolate
cumin chocolate has more cocoa butter
and it melts more smoothly and evenly
white chocolate is melted take from the
heat add in the 2 cup of cold heavy
cream and gently stir cool down this to
room temperature and put in a
refrigerator and cool down about two
hours two hours later white chocolate
mousse is set in a refrigerator and i'm
going to whip this
until it looks like a whipped cream i
want to eat this
looks really good we use a good
chocolate so i think this is a very nice
texture this is ready
so i want to make sure the cake is flat
so i'm going to cut a little bit domi
part so
it sits better
very nice smells good too
smells very fruity you use this bowl it
is the same size as my mold so i want to
use this as a guide
jelly it's completely set
still there okay so when you are molding
something very sticky like jelly or
pudding
you hold it and spin yourself
no
no it shouldn't work because i have done
that before
i'm so dizzy
yes
and i have a glass bowl lined with
plastic add mousse about one sand so i'm
going to use a little bit smaller bowl
as a guide for the jelly and add mousse
probably like half height of the bowl
but the jelly
mousse
second layer it's done topped with jolly
rancher fruitcake tuck it in freeze the
six hours to overnight but we have top
freezer and that saves some time one cup
of sugar 2 cup of water and 10 jolly
rancher it's a blue raspberry flavor
jordan's favorite cook over medium heat
and until jolie launcher is fully melted
while it is cooking i'm going to slice
some pears i'm using bundling because
you can slice it even thickness and very
thin but mandarin is one of the most
dangerous kitchen tool i have cut my
finger before so be careful hold
object like this not like this because
you're gonna slice your finger and i
think finger has more nerves so it's
more painful and once it's getting
difficult to hold i use kitchen towel so
it doesn't injure my finger i want to
use just a middle portion where it just
look like a slice of pear and i'm
slicing two of them
so you kind of want to peek through a
nice looking part those are all kind of
cute i didn't cut my finger well this
kind of makes me want to go vacation
like clear blue ocean
[Laughter]
i want to swim in this jolly rancher is
completely melted and i'm going to cook
pears in this syrup about 15 minutes or
until translucent so pretty it soaked up
all the jolly rancher color do the same
process with grapes watermelon and green
apple jolly rancher flavor and make
jolly ranchers soaked pears
dry and kind of remove extra moisture
put a piece of paper towel over put this
in a silicone baking mat bake this at
200 degrees about two hours and maybe go
to the next step we have jolly rancher
mousse cake remove frosting and i have
hot water here so
frozen cake release easily
remove the mold
and i have jolly ranchers soaked pears
and i'm going to decorate and i'm using
a simple syrup to the cake part it will
stick a little better
and you want to stick
these pears kind of overwrapping each
other it's beautiful i'm so happy how it
turns out it almost looks like a stained
glass you are just freestyling just
think about kind of balance of the color
and if it
doesn't stick together you can use
simple syrup and
kind of glue to the cake
it's kind of look like a pickle i'm
gonna heavy on the blue
color since it's her favorite once you
come to this mousse part
it is already wet so it's very easy to
stick
and we are done
[Music]
jolly rancher pear mousse cake very
fancy let's see what jordan thinks
oh my gosh you're real i made jolie run
your moose cake for you
i'm not watching from my phone right now
wow when what's what what's the first
episode like a long time ago oh wow but
now i am like like there's an episode
that drops on the first view oh gee make
it fancy fan you are over 21 right i am
okay
i am
i don't drink though but i know how you
are
you're true fun and when i made this
cake i didn't think about cutting it
so
i might struggle we're here for it
it looks beautiful
wow cheers
[Music]
you like yes
you made them fancy yay
if i ask you to
dance
can you make like special dance for us
oh my god yes so we can do like
make it fancy okay and we have like the
make it fancy like the full out version
i like the second one but i don't think
i can do it so you go like diagonal all
the way up uh-huh and then here
and then down okay or it could even just
go up and down yes
make it fancy
[Music]
you